VICTORIA: Hello, everybody.
Thanks so much for
coming to this talk
by my wonderful friend James
who is also a first time author.
I want to tell you three
quick things about James.
The first is that James'
book is about the importance
of experience.
And I want to vouch for the
fact that this guy doesn't just
talk the talk, he
walks the walk.
James and I met 14 years--
ago almost to this day--
on an overnight bus going from
Delhi to Rishikesh in India.
For those of you who
don't know Rishikesh,
it's supposed to be sort of
the yoga capital of the world,
the Beatles went there to
see the Maharishi Mahesh,
Jerry's ashes are
there, et cetera.
And I was, of course, there
to go and check myself
into an ashram to continue
to do the yoga that I
was in love with.
And James was there to learn
about this thing called yoga
that he'd heard about but
didn't really know what it was.
He said he was going to
be there for three days.
And after we went
into this ashram,
he sort of fell in
love with the Ashtanga,
and the macrobiotic
diet, and the meditation,
and the aura reading, and
even the homemade colonics,
and basically,
decided to stay there
for 30 days with
me, which is where
we became such great friends.
So this guy is the real deal.
The second thing is that
when we were in India,
James and I were
absolutely love struck.
Not with each other.
We actually both had
partners-- him in London
and me in the States, and we're
no longer with these people--
but we were so bored in
the ashram at night--
absolutely nothing goes
on in an ashram at night--
that we would write
these incredible love
letters to our
significant others,
and we would read
them to each other.
That's how bored we were.
And I can just tell you that he
is the most beautiful writer.
So I'm so happy that 14 years
later, he has written a book.
And the third
thing to tell you--
just because it will
endear him to you--
is that James is about to become
a father for the second time.
He didn't know if he would
be able to make it out here
in time before his
wife gives birth.
So I'm very happy
that he's here.
Welcome, James.
JAMES WALLMAN:
Thank you, Victoria.
That's pretty funny
because I haven't
heard that story for some time.
Especially, the bit about
writing the love letters
and reading them to each other.
Because I've actually found some
I never got around to sending.
And they are-- you know those
really embarrassing letters
that you never sent
for good reason?
So I'm touched that you
say I was a good writer,
but I think I wasn't back then.
But anyway, I appreciate
that very much.
It's great to be back
in Mountain View.
And I say back because I
lived in Palo Alto in 1997.
And I have a strong
connection to Mountain View--
a strong experiential
connection to Mountain View,
actually-- because
when I was here,
I learned how to scuba dive
with the Bayview Divers.
Anyone learn to scuba
dive in Mountain View?
I have the card.
It's the card I've been using
on this trip to the States
as my ID.
So every time I was
in New York before,
and I was going to buildings
like the Hearst Building,
the Conde Nast Building,
the Time & Life Building,
and they want to see ID.
And I gave them the ID
of this scuba diving card
I have from when I
was in my early 20s--
I mean I look completely
different, obviously-- Anyway,
and that was-- I
checked this out-- it
was before Google started.
It was a year before
Google started,
so I was here first, all right.
Thank you for
coming, first of all.
I really appreciate it.
For those of you that
don't have a copy,
the book is called
"Stuffication."
And what I'd like
to do is give you
an introduction to that,
where it came from for me.
And the best place, I think, to
begin a story of "Stuffication"
in a talk like this,
is a place where
I think a lot of
great stories begin.
In a time of war with
the young couple in love.
So about 70 years ago--
on January 27, 1940--
war was raging in
some parts of Europe.
But in London, it
was still quite.
It was a quiet night in London.
There was snow falling gently.
And just out of a busy,
bustling, noisy dance
hall, a man by the
name of Jack, wearing
a dark suit, a white
shirt, and a Dickey bow tie
stepped outside with
his new bride, Pam.
And he turned to Pam, and
he said to her, "Come on.
Let's go home."
And they tramped through
snow to their first home.
They had two rooms.
They had a living room
and they had a bedroom.
The kitchen and the
bathroom was shared
with the other people who
lived in the building.
A few years later,
they had a son, Allen.
And when Allen grew too big to
share the bedroom with them,
they gave him the bedroom.
So every night, after
Allen had gone to bed,
they would make up one
of those camp beds.
You know those camp beds?
They would make up a camp
bed in the living room,
and they would sleep there.
And every morning, before
Allen left for his paper route,
he would wake to the
sound of sizzling
and the smell of bacon,
and eggs, and sausages,
and something that
English people used
to eat called fried bread.
And Jack would get up
every morning, early,
and make that for Allen.
And he did that every
day until the day Allen
left for university-- for
Liverpool University-- in 1962.
Allen was the first
person in his family
ever to go to university.
He made the most of it.
He played for the
university soccer team.
Notice I said soccer.
He saw bands that
were hugely famous,
but he saw them before
they were famous.
So of course, he saw the
Beatles and the Rolling Stones.
And if you ever meet
him, he'll tell you
that within five
minutes of meeting him.
And then he did what most
of us do after university.
He settled down, he got a job,
he got married, he had kids,
and I'm one of them.
Allen is my father.
Jack is my grandfather.
This is my back story.
Why am I telling you this?
Because in the story of our
everyday, workaday family,
you can see the story
of stuffication.
In the story of our
very typical family,
you can see the shift
in circumstances
from scarcity to abundance.
And you can see the
change, as well,
in terms of what that means for
our attitudes, our aspirations,
and our values.
You see my grandparents, Jack
and Pam, they were typical.
They lived not so very
far from survival mode
as most people did back then.
And as 99% of humans had always
done since the dawn of time.
And my father was typical, too.
He was a typical,
materialistic baby boomer.
And as a typical,
materialistic baby boomer--
one of the key things he did was
that-- he measured his life--
in many ways-- in
material terms.
Like the homes he lived
in and the cars he drove.
And I remember them all.
From in the '70s, kind of
boxy, sky blue Triumph Toledo.
Anyone know what a
Triumph Toledo is?
But you can picture it.
British built.
It was OK.
And in the '80s, he
moved on to much slicker,
sportier, kind of curvier,
more imported cars.
And he ended the decade
in a red Porsche 911.
And he was typical,
too-- I think
for his time-- in
that he grew up
believing in the
counterintuitive idea,
we should gain ground in the
early 20th century, which
was at the very
heart of materialism.
And was sometimes called
the American paradox.
And that was the idea.
That if we wanted to have
more, we had to spend more.
A virtuous circle of materialism
that changed circumstances.
Now do you remember
the last time
you called someone
materialistic?
Have you done that
in the last month?
I ask people this, and
most people say nothing.
Then, this one.
Have you thought
someone's materialistic
in the last month?
OK.
And it's quite an insulting
thing to think isn't it right?
You're kind of
putting someone down.
And that makes sense today.
But back then,
saying someone was
materialistic-- materialism--
wasn't such a bad idea.
In fact, it made perfect
sense because it offered
my father, Alan, and the
rest of the baby boomers
the straightest route--
the straightest road--
from the scarcity they'd been
born into to the abundance
that they were
helping to create.
The abundance and
the better world
they were making for
themselves, for the society
around them, and
for their children.
So I grew up the benefactor
of that to a large extent.
And I also grew up
believing in that idea.
And I grew up thinking I
would be just like my dad.
I would be materialistic.
But then something happened.
And I think lots of
things have happened.
And they've all added up to this
situation I call stuffication
So stuffication is
that feeling you
get when you open up the closet,
and it's full of clothes,
but you can't find a
single thing to wear.
It's that feeling you
get when you root around
inside a cupboard-- whatever
it might be-- to find the one
thing you need through a pile
of stuff that you don't use.
Instead of thinking
of more-- the way
we used to-- as a
good thing, we now
think more means more
hassle, more to store,
more to manage,
more to think about.
More isn't better
anymore, it's worse.
I think overwhelmed,
suffocating from stuff,
we're feeling stuffication.
Why isn't materialism
working anymore?
Now, as with anything
as-- I think--
seismic of stuffication, there
are loads of different answers.
If you ask a different
expert, you'll
get a different emphasis.
So a philosopher might say that
it's to do with status anxiety.
We've had enough
of stuff because we
had enough of the
status anxiety that
comes with materialistic
consumerism.
A psychologist like Oliver
James might say it's affluenza.
We've had enough of
stuff because it's
giving us affluenza.
Mass consumption is
leading to mass depression.
And a political
scientist, might say it's
because of the stable society.
We're just not so
bothered about stuff
anymore because
we know that we're
going to have a roof
over our heads tonight,
and there's going to be
food on the table tomorrow.
We're just not so bothered
about the basic materialistic
concerns anymore.
We've climbed that first stage
of Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
An anthropologist
might say-- I'm
going to quote here
from the Center
on the Everyday Lives of people,
based in Los Angeles, which
has just completed the most
comprehensive report ever
conducted into how
people are living today.
And they said-- that
we have more material
things than any
preceding society.
They use the term "light-years
more possessions than any
preceding society
in human history."
That we're struggling
under material saturation,
there we're coping with
extraordinary clutter,
and that we're in the
middle of a clutter crisis.
And a technologist
might-- I think-- smile
at all of these ideas.
Ya sure, status anxiety,
affluenza, the stable society,
clutter crisis.
This is all relevant as to
why we've had enough of stuff.
But the real reason that we're
moving on from material things
is because we can.
Why have a room full of
Encyclopedia Britannicas when
you can search for
the answer you're
looking for through-- as
a search angle-- Google,
you can use.
Worth a try, that joke, right?
That's why I'm a
writer, not a comedian.
Anyway, but thanks.
But why have a car, why
have a second car, when
you can use Zipcar
or you can use Uber?
Why have a suitcase
full of books
when you go on holiday--
for those of you
that went on holiday
in the '70s and '80s--
it was a real
challenge about which
books were you going
to take with you.
But why do that when
you have a Kindle?
I think you know what it
looks like anyway right?
But that-- thousands of books--
why have a room full of books?
I think all of these
reasons is partly
responsible for stuffication.
But if you think
about them-- I think
what's really interesting about
them is none of them are blips.
None of them are
blips that are here
one year and likely
to be gone the next.
I think they're all observable,
observed, long-term trends.
And that's why I
think stuffication
is going to be the defining
problem of the 21st century.
So how do you solve a
problem like stuffication?
Now my job-- the job of a
trend forecaster, not comedian
as we've already
established-- is fascinating.
It gives me really
interesting insight,
gives me a really
unique viewpoint,
and it opens me up
to a lot of ridicule.
As Yogi Berra said, "It's
hard to make predictions,
particularly about the future.
And the thing is, if you're
going to make a prediction,
if you're going
to say something's
going to happen in the
future, at the very least,
you'd better have a
decent methodology.
So I don't look
into a crystal ball.
And I don't read tea
leaves, and I've tried.
Maybe in Rishikesh.
And I don't breath in vapors
by the Oracle at Delphi.
The method I use is
far less ancient,
but I think it's
far more robust.
It's inspired by
something a futurist--
called William
Gibson-- once said,
that "The future
is already here,
it's just not very
evenly distributed. "
And it's informed by a way
of reading cultural change,
which has been applied more than
5,000 times since it was first
codified by a sociologist
called Everett Rogers,
Iowa State University in 1962.
Some of you will
have heard of it.
It's the diffusion
of innovations.
And it's a way of reading
cultural change that works out
how ideas, innovations,
new ways of living,
working, cooking,
whatever it might be,
spread from the innovators--
the few innovators
to the early adopters, the
early majority, late majority,
and [INAUDIBLE].
So my job is to spot the
future here in the present.
It's to identify the
innovators in the innovations,
the big ideas that are
going to catch on and spread
from these few people to
the many in the mainstream.
So I've looked all around the
world looking for the answer,
looking to understand
this problem better
and to find an idea-- which
I think-- has the power,
has the legs, has the ability
to move from these few
to these many.
And as you can imagine, I've
run up many blind alleys.
I've kind of come
to lots of dead ends
and all kinds of things that
I thought were the answer.
Minimalism is a great example.
But of all the things
I've looked at--
and the book is,
to a large extent,
a kind of process of me
going through this one,
does this work?
This one, does it work?-- I've
come across one idea, which
I think is going to catch
on and become dominant.
I call it experientialism.
And the people who live
this way, experientialists.
So the experientialists,
instead of looking for status,
identity, happiness, and
meaning in material things--
like materialists
did-- experientialists
are finding status,
identity, happiness,
and meaning, and
experiences instead.
Experientialism-- and I've
said it a lot of times--
I think can solve a
problem like stuffication.
More importantly,
experientialism, I believe,
will solve stuffication.
And I say that because
firstly, it's better.
It's just better
the materialism.
Giving us status,
giving us identity,
giving us meaning in our
lives, and making us happy.
But more important than
that-- more important
than being better--
I've seen the signs.
I've seen the evidence.
Even if it's still
unevenly distributed,
that we are moving
away from materialism,
and the experientialism
is making the leap
from the innovative few to
the many in the mainstream.
So first up,
there's the evidence
that shows that our
attitudes are changing.
There's a guy called
Ron Inglehart-- he's
a political scientist at
the University of Michigan--
and based on a hunch that
Ron had back in 1969,
he started studying
our attitudes.
And in 1970, he found
that 80% of people
were materialistic
in Western countries.
Now-- in today's
world-- it's 50%.
So you can see very clear,
there is long-term decline
in how materialistic we are.
And I think where it's really
interesting is that, as well
as our attitudes changing,
there is now evidence
that our behavior is
changing, as well.
There's a guy called Chris
Goodall-- he's a Cambridge
grad, he was a
McKinsey consultant,
he taught economics at
Harvard for a time--
he has analyzed the material
flows-- the flow of materials--
through Western
economies, so looking
at the States and
the UK, for example.
And he's discovered that we
are consuming less stuff.
Less paper, concrete,
cars, steel, fertilizers,
electricity.
He's happy having
seen all this evidence
to conclude that we've reached
the point of peak stuff,
and that we're now
passing that point.
Now besides those
there's technology.
And I mean, technology in
terms of wearable tech.
For example, the quantified
self movement, life logging,
and social media.
All of these things
make our lives
much more connected, much
more trackable, and much more
sharable.
I imagine you're
aware of this, right?
What's really interesting for me
about all these technologies--
in particular, I think
the social aspect of it,
social media-- is
they're fundamentally
changing how we express our
identities and we get status.
So go back to the 20th century.
The best way to get status
and express your identity
in the 20th century,
was through the stuff
you owned-- handbag,
car, shoes, whatever
it might be-- not
from what you did.
Because back then,
who knew that you'd
been to Utah or Tahoe
skiing for the weekend?
Who knew you'd been to
Marrakech on your vacation?
Who knew you'd been to a
really great talk from a trend
forecaster at lunch time?
Thank you for staying
with me there.
I appreciate that.
My wife says that was a
funny joke, but they you go.
But the thing is,
in today's world,
with all your followers on
Twitter, Instagram, Google+,
and Facebook-- your friends,
fans, followers-- they do.
So now if you take a
picture from the chair
lift in Squaw
Valley or Park City,
or if you take a picture of the
sun setting behind the Atlas
mountains from the rooftop
of your riad in Marrakech,
or you even tweet a
quote from something
you heard a talk at lunch time.
And this matters.
This matters because
it matters for how
we express our identities
and we get our status.
And that matters for people
because status and identity
matters, right?
And social media
and this technology
matters for the rise
of experientialism
because this isn't the
innovative few anymore.
There are hundreds of millions
of people using Instagram,
Twitter, and Google+.
There's 1.2 billion
people on Facebook--
that's as many people as are
in the Catholic Church-- who
are expressing their identities
and getting their status,
not from what they have,
but from what they do.
And this matters-- I
believe-- for you, for me,
and for all of us.
The question is, I guess, how?
About 12 years ago--
on January 27, 2002--
my father brought
my grandparents--
Jack and Pam-- over for
lunch to my new apartment.
It was my first home.
It was in Brixton,
in south London
and it had three bedrooms.
I had a living room, I had
a separate dining room,
a separate kitchen, had this
great, big, west facing garden.
It was awesome for parties.
It was a great first home.
And they come over for lunch.
And I had a job in
advertising at the time.
I think I was a bit
gung-ho, talking
quite big about how successful
I was and was going to be.
And just before they
left, my grandfather
handed me an envelope.
And just after they left, I
opened it, as you can imagine.
And it had a note in it.
And it had on it 27/1/2002-- he
wrote the date the British way
with the day and then the
month-- "On this day in 1940,
Nana and I tramped through
snow to our first home.
Memories live
longer than dreams.
Good luck."
A little bit later-- probably 20
to 25 minutes later-- my father
was just driving back starting
to cross the river Thames--
it was a black 5 Series
BMW, if you're keep up
with the cars of my father--
and my grandfather choked.
And he kind of
collapsed in his seat.
My father obviously stopped.
And then he drove
as fast as he could.
He jumped lights.
He actually got pulled over
and got a police escort.
He did everything he could
to get my grandfather
to a hospital as
quickly as possible.
He did what he could, but my
grandfather died that day.
And obviously, I
thought about the note
that he gave me quite
a lot since then.
First of all, did
he know that he
was going to die that day
when he gave me that note?
And what did he mean by memories
live longer than dreams?
Did he mean that the past is
not as good as the future?
Or did he mean-- as I've come
to believe-- that the material
dreams are all well
and good, but life
is made of up memories,
which come from experiences?
Now whatever he meant, it
was quite a passing shot.
In those final
moments, to address
the most important
question a person can ask.
The question that Aristotle
asked in the Nicomachean
Ethics, almost 2 and
1/2 thousand years ago.
The question every one of us
should ask-- as individuals,
as parents, as
influential people
who market stuff and change the
world, being citizens or where
we work, whatever it might be.
And the question is-- I think
you know the question, right?
How should we live
in order to be happy?
And in the 20th century,
I think the answer
to that, in many
ways, was clear.
You should be
materialistic because that
was creating abundance
for everybody.
And I think in the 21st
century, when our problem isn't
scarcity, our problem is
abundance-- I think so much
abundance that there's time
of stuffication-- I think
that quite the answer has
fundamentally changed.
So the story of
stuffication ends with you.
What are you going to do about
the most pressing problem
of our time?
There are 3 things you can do
to try out experientialism.
Three steps.
First step, destufficate.
Step two, don't restufficate.
Once you've gone through
the bother of getting
rid of all that stuff you
don't wear, you don't need,
you don't use.
And it's so easy to
go out when you've
created space in your
closet on your shelf,
because we've been trained
to be consumers, to do that.
But it's really important
not to go out and buy
more stuff you don't need,
you don't use, you don't wear.
But for me, step
3 is the best bet.
Because 1 and 2 are
just hygiene factors.
They're just starting points.
Step 3 is a game.
And it's a game I like to think
of as the Brewster's Millions
game.
Some of you probably won't
have read the 1902 novel
or seen the 1985 movie.
Anyone got no idea what
Brewsters Millions is?
All right.
Oh, a few of you.
OK.
It only got 6.4 out of 10 on
IMDB, which is a crying shame
and it's wrong.
It's a great movie.
Anyway.
So Brewster's
Millions, the movie,
is about this guy who has to
spend $30 million in a month
and have nothing physical,
tangible to show for it.
Now to play the
game properly, you
don't have to spend $30 million
in a month, unless you have it,
that's obviously your choice.
But what you do have to do--
to play the game properly
and to really experience
the benefits-- is
to spend the same
amount of money
that you'd spend
in a normal month,
but have nothing
physical, tangible
to show for it at the end.
And that's all you have to do
to join the experientialists.
And if you do that-- I promise
you-- you'll have more stories,
you'll have more status,
you'll be happier,
life will feel like it
has a lot more meaning.
But more than that, I think
you'll be one of the pioneers.
I think you'll be one
of the pioneers leading
the rest of society out of
the storm of stuffication
on the straightest, most
positive, most aspirational,
most fun route to
a better world.
I think you'll be one
of the pioneers leading
the rest of America,
the rest of the West,
the rest of the world from
the old age of materialism
to this new era of
experientialism.
And more than that
even, I think you'll
understand what my
grandfather, Jack, meant
that memories live
longer than dreams.
Thank you.
Questions, if anyone has any.
AUDIENCE: So if we take this to
the end, and everybody becomes
destuffified, and
we are so good at it
that everybody around the
world becomes destuffified--
JAMES WALLMAN: Destufficated,
but I like your version.
AUDIENCE: That's right.
So then what happens to Google?
JAMES WALLMAN: Great
question, I think.
OK.
So I'm just going to
repeat that back to you.
If everyone becomes
destuffified,
what happens to Google?
Can you be a little
more specific?
I think I know
what you're saying.
If you take it to
its purest end,
like we need to go
to the grocery store.
We need stuff, certain stuff.
I guess what I'm confused
about in implementing
this in my own life is,
what do you spend money
on-- it's kind of a riddle--
on and have nothing
to show for it?
You know what I mean?
JAMES WALLMAN: OK.
That's a great question.
So how do you
spend money and not
end up with
something at the end?
When did you last go holiday?
AUDIENCE: Friday.
JAMES WALLMAN: Oh, great.
Friday.
Please give the man a mic.
Where did you go?
AUDIENCE: I went and
bought a new car.
JAMES WALLMAN: OK.
Can I-- just to get a
little bit of clarity here,
that's not playing the game.
A holiday is not buying a car.
You've actually picked up on
two very brilliant examples
of different purchases.
I have a car and
I take holidays.
I would conceive one of
those-- don't get me wrong,
it gives me experiences--
but one is quite a material
purchase.
The thing about
not having anything
at the end of it, a great
example is a holiday.
That's why I wanted to
follow it down that route.
I didn't know you were
going to play nasty.
So let's say you go
skiing for a week.
What do you have,
physically, at the end of it?
You might have some
pictures on your telephone,
but, really what you've
had, is a great time.
Or let's say you go
on a stag party, which
is a-- what do you
call it over here?
Bachelor Party.
You don't take any
pictures, right?
But you have an amazing time.
It gives you [INAUDIBLE] and
identity are quite closely
connected, gives
you real identity,
it gives you, hopefully,
some happiness.
You've had a good time, if
you can remember any of it.
And it gives life
a sense of meaning.
But you don't come back from
it with a whole bunch of stuff,
do you?
Hopefully, you've lost stuff.
Anyway, so just to
be really clear.
So in terms of what I
mean by experiences,
is that which is something
where you're doing something
rather than having something.
That's the kind of
classic distinction.
There's two psychologists--
called [INAUDIBLE]
and Tom Gilovich-- and they had
a paper they published in 2003
called, "To Do or To Have?
That Is the Question."
And it was-- it is--
considered to be
the kind of classic
moment in research.
To find, for the first
time, whether material goods
or experiential goods gave
people more happiness.
And they proved,
for the first time,
that experiential goods
gave people more happiness.
But to begin that
piece of research,
they started by saying,
what's a material good?
What's an experiential good?
Because for some people, a TV is
experiential, and some people,
it's material.
Just to be really clear,
this is not anti-consumerist,
it's not anti-capitalists,
it's not even anti stuff.
It's totally pro
consumers, pro capitalist,
and it's not anti stuff.
It's having stuff.
We bought a bread maker
a couple of weeks ago.
Now that has got the potential
to be a waste of money.
But my wife insists
that we will use it--
and we fully intend
to-- in which case,
it's got use, right?
So it's not anti
having stuff, it's
anti having too much stuff.
Does that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: That does.
Yeah.
I now know how to implement
your three principles.
JAMES WALLMAN: Great.
Thank you.
Good.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I think you make some
very interesting points.
I mean, I can relate to what
you say in terms of my parents
lived a simpler life than me.
My grandparents
lived a simpler life.
And they were happier.
They were more social.
They interacted
with more people.
They had fewer things.
Another trend I've
seen in my generation
is not just materialism,
but it's also boredom.
People are just bored.
If we have so many things to do.
We have more to do,
we are always bored.
I've never heard that word
from my previous generations.
So do you see a correlation
between the two?
JAMES WALLMAN: That's
a great question
that no one has asked me in
any presentation I've given.
So you-- can I just say back
to you-- saying there are so
many things to do, we're bored.
AUDIENCE: People get
bored with their job.
They have more opportunity,
but every type of person
you talk to, their like,
I'm so bored with my job.
Whereas, if I look at my uncle--
who worked at the same place
for 30 years-- he never
used the term bored.
They were just happy
doing what they did.
JAMES WALLMAN: I'd really like
to give a good answer generally
but I don't know
if I have an answer
because I think having loads of
possibilities-- I mean, boredom
is your own
responsibility, right?
It comes to the weekend
and you've got a choice
of-- especially where
you guys live, right?--
there's so many outdoor
activities you can do.
Or you can go to San Francisco.
I mean, the world's,
kind of, here.
There's so many
things we can do now.
I think being bored is terrible.
And if you're bored of your job,
you should do a different job.
I, personally, am
infused by my job.
And it's been my
experience of the people
that I-- I was in New
York for a few days,
I've now been here in
California for a few days,
and everyone-- I've talked to
seems to be really fired up.
We went to a great
Super Bowl party
and no one seemed bored at all.
I don't know, is this
just a general malaise?
OK.
Because I would have thought,
if you've got more things to do,
it's just a question
of having-- there
are challenges with attention.
Absolutely no doubt about it.
There are challenges with
sticking with something
long enough to enjoy it.
But I don't know if I can
answer that better than that.
AUDIENCE: It's probably related
to lack of attention span.
Over time, we've
lost attention span
with so many things around us.
Kind of like you said,
we open our closet,
but we don't like anything.
And it's like, what is it
that we're looking for?
We have lost that,
to some extent.
JAMES WALLMAN:
Well you can become
a kind of zombie consumer.
You just buy more
stuff because you
think it's going
to solve problems.
You're going to turn
to retail therapy.
But that's the truth
about retail therapy,
in terms of buying stuff, it
won't make you any happier.
But if you buy an
experiential good,
like going on a rock
climbing course,
you'll be so scared you
won't be able to be bored.
So if you're bored, go
rock climbing, or skiing,
or surfing.
That's frightening, too.
AUDIENCE: What's different
with social media
now replacing some of the
materialistic aspects of that
is different from coming
back with a bunch of slides
or coming back with some videos
that I took on my camcorder?
JAMES WALLMAN: Great question.
Thank you.
I think this comes to the heart
why social media is important.
If you-- I'm going to guess
you're in your 20s, right?
AUDIENCE: Just left them.
JAMES WALLMAN: OK.
So if you went on holiday in
the '90s, or your friends--
you ever remember going to a
friend's house in the '90s,
and they-- would pull
out their holiday snaps.
And there was that that
awful moment where you think,
Oh, God.
And they'd show you a
picture Jean at the Acropolis
and then Jean eats souvlaki and
then Jean doing something else.
How painfully dull
was that, right?
And it took them-- if
you think about it--
how long did it
take them to share
their holiday with people?
Because they would have had
to have, not just you around,
all their other friends.
So let's say it's
the '90s, and you
go on a really
incredible holiday.
Let's say you go to Greece, and
you're really excited about it,
and you go see the
ruins, et cetera.
And you want to tell
100 of your best friends
about your holiday.
And let's say-- it's hard
to do it at a party--
so you need to see them at
dinner or at personal drinks,
right?
So let's say you can
manage 6 people at a time.
Stay with me here for the math.
So you've got to have 10,
15 different arrangements
to see people.
That takes a long time-- takes
like a couple of months--
to share with people
your experiences.
Whereas today, you could
post it on Facebook,
and you've got your
500, 600 friends that
are right there that can see it.
So what social media has done
has catalyzed that opportunity
to share what you're doing.
So if you'd just
run a Tough Mudder
course-- I think this is one of
the reasons why Tough Mudder is
increasing so quickly--
you can instantly
share that with people.
And that has a real impact
on how you see yourself.
It has a real impact on how you
present yourselves to others.
So that's what social
media has done.
I constantly hear
about Facebook,
it'll be something else next.
It doesn't matter which platform
it is that people are using.
We now are used to the
idea of social media.
It will stay with us.
Now that means there's
been a fundamental shift
from having things
to doing things
in terms of expressing
our identities.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a Millennial,
a group about whom our consumer
behavior as much
has been speculated.
We are the group least likely
to buy a car now, least
likely to buy a house.
And I always get a
little weary when
I hear about how
people are like,
oh, your generation just values
Instagram and social media
and you like experiences more
than things because you just
like sharing your every
thought on Facebook.
Mostly, it's actually
because I think
were less likely to buy cars
because-- like me instead--
you're spending the equivalent
of a brand new BMW S
series on your education.
And so it's not so much that
I like Instagraming photos
from my bike ride more, as I
feel like I have actually less
money to spend on stuff.
And so I'm wondering what
the recession you feel
might play into this movement
away from stuff, how you think
it's maybe going to be different
for people for my generation,
for whom, things are
just going to become
less part of the picture
because of the rising
cost of other things, like
healthcare, like education.
And whether or
not you think then
that some of your advice on how
you would implement those three
steps would be different.
JAMES WALLMAN: Good questions.
I think you've asked me
quite a lot of things there.
I'm going to try
to say back to you.
No, it's fine.
It's really interesting.
, Especially since you are
a Millennial, it's very easy
for me stand here and say,
Millennial's are doing this,
but you are a Millennial.
So you're asking me,
how should a Millennial
implement those three steps?
That was your final part, but
before that you were saying,
what do I think about education?
Where does education
fit into this?
And the economy.
Education, economy,
and how does that
affect Millennials and
this shift from materialism
to experientialism.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm wondering
how you see the recession
and rising costs of education is
factoring into people's choice
not to buy things.
JAMES WALLMAN: All right.
So the economy is a
really complicated one--
to be frank with you--
because it's certainly
something I would
never try and forecast.
Because there's so much.
In terms of how it
affects people--
I think is really
interesting because-- there's
a particular time of your life
and if there is a recession--
or there's a lack of money in
your family around that time--
you become much
more materialistic
than other people.
So this kind of
broad brush approach,
that the boomers were this,
and the Millennials are this,
and Gen X are like this,
it's quite broad brush
over-- generalizations.
And there will be different
people within that.
My brother and I
are two years apart,
and he is far more
materialistic than me.
Because not long after my
father having that Porsche,
his company disappeared.
And therefore, all
the money did as well.
Therefore, my brother went
through a crucial period
where we had no money.
And therefore, he's much
more materialistic than I am.
So the economy will affect
this is an interesting way.
And some people will
feel less stable
and therefore, become
more materialistic.
But we've also had
recessions before.
That kind of comes and goes.
I don't know if
you Nate Silver's
"The Signal and the Noise" but
if you consider how forecasting
works, and the way
that trends work,
you may consider the idea
that 80% of people that
were materialistic,
and now it's 50%.
Within that time, it
will go down a bit.
So I think there's
still a long term trend.
In terms of
education, I would say
education is a great example
of an experiential good.
It's not tangible.
I don't know what your
educational situation is,
but for those of us that have
a degree of the first level,
the next level, or a doctorate,
how many of us have the--
do you get
certificates over here?
Do you keep them?
I have no idea where
my certificates are.
I don't think my
mom has them even.
It's very much an
experiential good.
It's not a material good.
It's not a kind of solid thing.
And as a Millennial, in
terms of those three ideas,
I don't actually think it
makes a difference what age
or who you are.
The simple aspect of it is,
if you want to be happier--
And the research is fascinating.
If you look at the
research that experiential
versus material goods.
There's one great example.
People are happier, if they
talk about experiences.
And we enjoy listening
to people that
talk about experiences more.
So on that basis, if
you've got a choice,
you're feeling bored
on a Saturday morning,
go spend your money and
time doing an experience.
You'll be happier because
you'll be doing it.
You'll be happier because when
you talk to people about it,
you'll be happier.
And you'll have more
friends because people
will want to listen to you more.
So an experiential good
is so much more positive.
The other aspects about a
experiential good-- as opposed
a material good--
have you ever bought
a pair of shoes that squeak
when you walk in them?
Or those trousers
that seem to swish?
Or a coat.
What do you do with those
shoes, or those things?
You wear them but
they annoy you.
You never want to wear them.
Eventually, you throw them
away or do you just squeak?
Maybe you do.
The thing about a material good,
if you buy a material good,
and it's not very good, there's
nothing you can do about it.
You bought a bad good.
That's it.
If you have an experience
that goes wrong.
The bus trip
across-- I was going
to say a bus trip across
India [INAUDIBLE],
but since that was
a fun bus trip.
But the bus trip across
India-- or Peru, or Columbia,
or Thailand where
it all goes wrong.
Have you all been
on one of those?
The person next to you was sick,
or some other unpleasant thing
was happening, the
windows wouldn't shut
or they wouldn't open,
it was too hot, too
cold, you were sick.
It all went wrong.
It was supposed to take
2 hours, it took 3 days.
Have you all been
one of those trips?
And how bad was it at the time?
And how amazing is it now?
And that's the funny
thing about experiences.
If you buy an experience,
and it's really bad,
it's actually brilliant.
So my advice to you would be
shift from material things
to experiences.
It has a lot of other
knock on effects as well.
The environment, for example.
But yeah, those are reasons.
AUDIENCE: I'm
wondering how you not
get stufficated by the
stuff of experience.
So for example, if you go
skiing, you have the skis.
You might have the scuba gear.
You have the bread maker.
You have all that stuff, right?
Maybe you go to
Thailand, and you
buy that beautiful painting,
but you went to Peru,
and you bought this other thing.
All of a sudden, your
house is full of stuff,
but it's all related
to experience.
So how do you not
get stufficated?
JAMES WALLMAN: That
is a great question.
It's funny, there's a
bit in the book where
I, kind of, really take that on.
There's a guy in the
book called Ben Howe.
He's an Australian.
If you go to his house in
Adelaide in South Australia,
he's got a really regular house.
If anything, it's not messy,
but it's not completed.
You know, you walk into
your friend's house
and sometimes think, how
long have you lived here?
And you think
they've been a month,
but they've been there years.
It's kinda that.
But you go to the garage,
and you put up the, kind of,
rickety door, it's
full of stuff.
He's got his motorbike in there,
he's got his kite surfing kit,
he's got his wind surfing kit,
he's got his rock climbing kit,
he's got his skiing kit.
I'm not anti stuff.
The message of stuffication
is not anti stuff,
it's anti too much stuff.
It's anti focus on stuff.
I wish I mentioned the bread
maker because that really
is stuff.
But anyway, the smell of fresh
bread, it's a lovely thing.
But if you want to ski, you
have to have things to do that.
At the same time,
a walk in the park
is an experience you can have
and don't need a lot of stuff
apart from feet.
And if you look at statistics,
if you live near a park,
you will be happier.
It's just one of those facts.
So and you mentioned going to
Peru and buying the painting,
you don't have to
buy that painting.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES WALLMAN: Well I've been
to Peru, I have no paintings.
[INAUDIBLE] No
paintings from Peru.
I have a couple of paintings.
But I remember it really
well-- I heard a howler monkey,
for example-- and this
was certainly in an era
before I had a telephone
that could record sounds--
but I can remember the sound
of that surreal howler monkey
to this day.
I hadn't talked about
that howler monkey
for about a decade, so thank you
for bringing that back to me.
But you don't need to have
stuff to have an experience.
Although, the two
sometimes come together.
AUDIENCE: Could there
be too many experiences?
To the point where
the value of them
is lessened because you're
doing so many things?
I think my life has
shifted in that way.
I don't have a car, I've lived
in so many different places,
so I could always purge.
And I'm always Tahoe
or Europe or whatever.
But maybe you're searching
for something big,
like bigger the next time.
Could it dull what's important
and what makes you happy?
JAMES WALLMAN: Thank you.
It's a really good
question as well.
And its really interesting
talking to people that move
country a lot.
They get this so quickly
because they do the country move
purge all the time.
And by definition of moving
from one country to another,
they're appreciating
the experience
of going to another country.
They tend to be more interested
in this kind of thing.
And I've spent a couple ski
seasons in the mountains.
At the end of five months
of being at a ski resort--
I have to be honest-- it sort
of loses some of its fizz,
compared to right
at the beginning.
And for someone who's
got so many experiences,
that your signs get
dulled by experiences,
that is a great problem to have.
Let's be really clear here.
Stuffication is a
fantastic problem to have.
Scarcity-- not having enough--
is a horrible problem to have,
actually.
And I'm not saying this
for everyone in the world.
This is for rich,
Western countries.
Other countries don't
have nearly the abundance
that we have per capita,
but as a whole country.
So stuffication is a
great problem to have.
If you get to the point where
you've done wind walking,
you've flown in helicopters,
you've been skiing in Kashmir,
you've spent time with monkeys,
whatever it might be, right?
If you've got to the point
where you're stufficated
with experience, are you saying
you're at that point now?
Because I'd say that is an
amazing problem to have.
The thing is as well
here, is that there's
an element of the material
versus the experiential choice,
being a first level
heuristic-- a kind
of simple way of making the
right choice-- because one
of the key things about this
actually is, is it extrinsic
or is it intrinsic?
In terms of how you
make the decision.
So if you buy material
good for yourself--
So I'm not trying to show off
to you about my break maker.
I really mean that-- I'm buying
the bread maker because we
discussed it and
we think we will
enjoy having that experience.
And fresh bread is really
expensive in London,
by the way.
I don't want to fixate
on this bread maker.
But we the decision for us.
We're not doing as an extrinsic
thing to say, hey, look at us,
we bought a bread maker.
And it can be the with
same with experiences.
You know those
people who will go
to the place to go on holiday.
They'll read a magazine and
go that's the place I have
to go on holiday
because then I can
tell people I've been there.
You know these people?
You all have friends like
that, or acquaintances?
You don't get as
much pleasure if you
buy that experiential good
for an extrinsic reason,
than if you buy it for
an intrinsic reason.
But-- and this is why I like
the distinction between material
and experiential
decisions-- even if you
buy that experiential good
to show off to other people--
to tell people who you are other
than doing it for yourself--
you'll still be
doing that thing.
Let's say you
decided that you have
to ski in Squaw Valley--
for the sake of argument--
now there's snow
there, you've decided
that you have to do that so
you can tell your friends
you've done it.
You'll still be skiing
in Squaw Valley.
Do you see what I mean?
So that's why I think
that distinction works.
But if you get to that point
the stufficate with experiences,
let's definitely talk.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the risk
that we are replacing
one problem with just another?
With stuffing our lives with
experiences and actually,
our time is much more limited
than this pace we have.
So is it a better way to
live your life actually,
or should we actually look
for even another answer.
Make time to think and not
just to get our experiences
going for holidays, new
restaurants, and so on.
JAMES WALLMAN: It's a
really good question.
Thank you.
Often when I'm
explaining this-- and I
give a talk on this-- I tend to
talk about things that you do,
actively do.
Because probably, it's
easier to visualize,
and it makes it a bit more
interesting to listen to.
But sitting, thinking
is an experience,
as far as I'm concerned.
And I don't think
that we're replacing
one problem with another.
I think we're replacing one
problem with something that
is exponentially better.
And I agree with you that
we only have so much time.
Experiences take time.
But that's life.
And the choice of
experiences that you do
are the choice of what you
do with your time, that's
what you do with
your life, right?
As opposed to you're saying that
there's more space for stuff
and therefore, we should
spend money on stuff
because we've got lots of space.
If you look at demographics and
the urbanization of the world,
we have less space.
There's seven billion people
now, it might be nine billion
by 2050.
More people living in
cities, less space.
So I think we have
less space, but I
think the most important part
of your question was about time.
The other thing
about experientialism
is a focus on what
you do with your time.
It's about your experiences.
And what could be more
important than what
you do with your time, as
opposed to the stuff you buy?
So in terms of the refocus from
material things to experiences,
I think there's a refocus
on life and what matters.
AUDIENCE: My
question is about how
do you with people becoming
less and less materialistic--
compared to even 40 years
ago, as Mr. Inglehart said--
how do you think it's going
to influence job market?
Because not all of
us can make a living
writing programs
or writing books.
Some of us, for example,
enjoy creating stuff.
Sewing or something like that.
So if we're going to
be less materialistic,
is that going to become
a problem for people
who are making their
living producing stuff
and selling stuff?
JAMES WALLMAN: It's a
very interesting aspect
of the problem of materialism
and the defining problem
stuffication.
The shift from the material
to experiential economy
is what's going to happen
to some industries.
With any change, there are
winners and there are losers.
You ever heard of a guy called
Ned Ludd, who led the Luddites?
Ever heard the
phrase, the Luddites?
So when the Industrial
Revolution got going in the UK,
this guy in the north of England
smashed some of the machines.
He may have just been
drunk-- it turns out
he may have not been
protesting at all.
Apparently, if you look
into it, it's really odd--
but he became their
hero and they and they
called themselves Luddites
because those machines were
taking away their jobs, and
they were hugely concerned.
Did that stop the
Industrial Revolution?
No.
Should it have stopped
the Industrial Revolution?
Not at all.
Because it was the
Industrial Revolution that
led to the consumer evolution
that gave us abundance,
that gave us everything
that we have today.
So there will definitely be
changes in the job market.
And definitely be changes
in terms of what we value.
And I think it will
change for the better.
You think about 3D
printing, what's
3D printing going to do for all
those people who make stuff?
When you can 3D
print it at home,
it's going to completely
change that market, isn't it?
Why you going to have loads of
factories of people producing
plastic goods, when you
can print it at home?
So the world is
changing, anyway.
And what I'm hoping-- this is
my belief-- what materialism
did for standards of living
in the 20th century, which
was just revolutionized them
in a way that just had never
happened in the whole
of human existence.
I think experientialism could
do that for quality of life
in the 21st century.
We could end up in
this age of leisure,
which [INAUDIBLE] talked
about back in the '30s.
That's what I hope.
SPEAKER: OK.
Why don't we thank
our speaker today.